[Musik]
es sind dunkle
Tage nicht nur im
Kalender sondern vor allem für die
Ampel Stunde um Stunde Ringen die
Spitzen der Koalition derzeit um
Einsparungen abgeschottete Sitzungen
bisher ohne konkretes
Ergebnis 17 Milliarden Euro muss das
Trio Scholz habck Lindner für 20
zusammenkratzen nicht mehr ausgeben als
die Schuldenbremse erlaubt im Grunde
nicht mehr ausgeben als man
einnimmt es müssen sich jetzt nur alle
verständigen und wir tun das in
intensiven Gesprächen diese
Verständigung
voranzubringen aber für mich ist ganz
klar es wird in einer solchen Situation
keinen Abbau des Sozialstaats in
Deutschland geben erstmals zieht der
Kanzler gestern öentlich eine rote Linie
schluss mit den Debatten ums Bürgergeld
so seine Botschaft und seine Partei
setzt noch einen drauf beschließt dass
man erneut die Notlage im Haushalt
erklären will um mehr Schulden machen zu
dürfen es sind diese
maximalfderungen die die Einigung
erschweren dem fdpchef und
Finanzminister hängen dabei nicht nur
SPD und Grüne im Nacken in dieser Woche
übergeben Basismitglieder Stimmen für
eine parteiabstimmung über den Verbleib
in der Koalition auch die Liberalen
definieren ihre roten Linien seit Tagen
keine Steuererhöhungen keineen neuen
Schulden wir haben gerade von Karlsruher
etwas gehört über die Schuldenbremse des
Grundgesetzes das muss man jetzt
respektieren und darf nicht neue Umwege
suchen und auch der Vizekanzler versucht
früh seine Klimaprojekte zu retten 60
Milliarden wollte er in den nächsten
Jahren aus dem jetzt verbotenen
Schattenhaushalt Zurückhaltung kom
missbereitschaft oder öffentliche Demut
Fehlanzeige es fehlen 60 Milliarden für
die Transformation und die Unterstützung
der Industrie mit der Industrie und der
Bedrohung der industriellen Kraft dieses
Landes ist natürlich auch eine Bedrohung
der Arbeitsplätze in der Industrie
verbunden die Ampel nimmt ganz
Deutschland in Geiselhaft Häuslebauer
Wärmepumpenhersteller
Chemieunternehmen bürgergeldempfänger
keiner weiß was gilt jetzt eigentlich
wirklich dem 1. das geht schon seit
Wochen so und dieses Riesenchaos das hat
ausschließlich die Ampel verursacht es
ist die Unwissenheit die derzeit fast
jede Spekulation zulässt der SPD
Arbeitsminister Hubertus Heil der sich
gern mal mit gewöhnlichen Arbeitnehmern
fotografieren lässt sucht trotz
Machtwort des Kanzlers offenbar nach
Geld im
Sozialetat die grüne Familienministerin
diesa Paus lässt angeblich eine
Verschiebung der Kindergrundsicherung
prüfen und das Stellvertreter als
fdpchef Johannes Vogel schlägt
Einschnitte bei der Rente vor es kommt
mir sehr dilittantisch vor dass man
keinen Plan B hat aber am meisten
schockiert mich das muss ich schon sagen
dass man gerade bei Sozialleistung bei
der Kindergrundsicherung bei dem
Bürgergeld wirklich ernsthaft diskutiert
dies zu reduzieren dort zu sparen als
die Haushaltspolitiker der Koalition den
ETA 2024 vorstellten war das Urteil aus
Karlsruhe noch frisch und sie selbst
ratlos drei Wochen später verbreiten sie
Zuversicht auch wenn sie offensichtlich
nicht jede Strategie der ampelspitzen
teilen wir sind ja drei ganz
unterschiedliche Parteien in dieser
Koalition und natürlich ist es für jede
Partei wichtig zu sagen wofür sie
eigentlich steht was ihr Wesenskern ist
grundsätzlich ist es wichtig dass die
drei Regierungs Spitzen also der Kanzler
Vizekanzler Finanzminister sich
öffentlich zurückhalten du kannst nicht
da alleine die Dinge durchsetzen die du
willst da sind zwei Koalitionspartner
und mit denen musst du dann eben
ernsthaft verhandeln am Abend soll es
weitergehen im Kanzleramt ohne
vereinbarte Endzeit dafür mit einer
neuen roten Linie des
Kanzlers und bei mir begrüße ich jetzt
einen der führenden Köpfe der Liberalen
den Vorsitzenden der Bundestagsfraktion
der FDP Christian D schönen guten Abend
guten Abend Frau Ben Herr sie haben es
gehört der Kanzler sagt finger weg von
den Sozialausgaben das ist ausgerechnet
ein Posten bei dem sie als Liberale
immer eine große ein großes einspar
Potenzial gesehen haben ist das etwas
was Christian Lindner heute abend
überdenken muss wenn er ins Kanzleramt
geht muss er da sagen okay da gehen wir
nicht mehr dran na es geht darum einen
verfassungsfesten Haushalt 2024 zu
bekommen wir haben ein Urteil des
Verfassungsgericht das eine
buchungspraxis verworfen hat in Bund und
Ländern und vor allen Dingen haben wir
bereits vor zwei Jahren ja den Hebel in
der Haushaltspolitik umgelegt die
Schuldenquote geht in Deutschland zurück
also es geht darum weniger Schulden zu
machen die Konsolidierung ist auch ein
Markenzeichen dieser Koalition und jetzt
muss man sich über die ein einzelnen
Dinge unterhalten ich halte da wenig von
roten Linien und gleichzeitig habe ich
den Bundeskanzler aber jetzt nicht so
verstanden dass es um rote Linien geht
und es geht ja in Wahrheit auch nicht
darum den Sozialstaat einzureißen
beispielsweise bei der Frage der
Arbeitsanreize haben wir jetzt eine neue
Studie im Auftrag des
bundesarbeitsministers die wir uns genau
anschauen wie man mehr Menschen Arbeit
kriegt also ich würde nicht so negativ
argumentieren sondern es geht doch
eigentlich darum dass wir mehr
Erwerbsbeteiligung schaffen und das
würde auch den Staat entlasten das ist
interessant dass sie sagen sie sehen da
gar keine klare rote Linie denn wenn man
sich den SPD Parteitag gestern angeguckt
hat wo Olaf Scholz sich geäußert hat
dann hat die SPD das offensichtlich ganz
anders aufgenommen die hat da großen
Jubel und viel Applaus für erteilt und
der Kanzler war ja auch klar in seiner
Wortwahl er hat gesagt also
Sozialausgaben werden nicht mit mir
gekürzt noch mal zur Klarstellung ist
das für die FDP also jetzt vom Tisch
oder nicht ne der Kanzler sprach von
Sozialabbau und es geht ja nicht darum
den Sozialstaat einzureißen oder kaputt
zu machen gar sondern es geht darum zu
schauen wie man mehr Menschen Arbeit
bringt und ich glaube da ist man sich
gar nicht so uneinig in dieser Koalition
noch mal bei der Einführung des
Bürgergelds haben wir ja schon bei den
arbeitsanreizen beispielsweise für
Auszubildende vieles geschaffen die
dürfen heute mehr von ihrem
selbstverdienten behalten also ich
glaube ne ich glaube aber da ist man gar
nicht so weit auseinander es geht nicht
darum den sozialstad gleichermaßen
kaputt zu machen aber natürlich führt es
dazu wenn Menschen mehr Menschen im Job
sind mehr Menschen arbeiten mehr
Menschen eine Ausbildung und mehr
Lebenschancen haben beispielsweise dass
das natürlich auch zuur Entlastung des
Bundeshaushaltes beitritten sie sagen es
geht nicht darum den Sozialstaat kaputt
zu machen dennoch sind sie auf viel
Kritik als FDP gest bei den
Sozialdemokraten mit Vorschlägen wie
etwa Kürzungen oder Einschnitten beim
Bürgergeld bei der Kindergrundsicherung
wir haben es immer wieder gehört in den
vergangenen Wochen von der FDP beim
sozialen besteht noch Einsparpotenzial
wenn ich sie jetzt richtig verstehe
nehmen Sie davon Abstand nee es geht
nicht um Abstand nehmen ich sagte gerade
die arbeitsanreiz sind das
allerwichtigste mehr Menschen in Lohn
und Brot zu bekommen das muss das zel
sein das hilft aber natürlich klar wenn
mehr Menschen Beitragszahler sogar
werden in die Versicherungs und in die
Steuerkasse dann ist das ja wesentlich
besser als wenn sie Empfänger sind also
nicht verordnen ja doch aber klar das
kann der Staat nicht verordnen aber er
kann seinen Beitrag leisten deswegen
sagt ich beispielsweise diese
sogenannten Hinzuverdienstgrenzen sind
ganz wichtiger Punkt und da trägt die
Studie des bundesarbeitsministers ja
direkt dazu bei sich das noch mal genau
anzuschauen noch mal Frau benery wir
sind auf einem konsolidierungsfahr seit
zi Jahren die Schuldenquote geht
merklich in Deutschland zurück wir sind
stabiler finanziell geworden und ich
fand es ganz spannend was Jens Spahn von
in Beitrag der war ja mal Bundesminister
in einem ehemaligen Kabinett wo Geld für
alles mögliche ausgegeben worden ist wir
haben bereits die Konsolidierung
eingeleitet und ich reite dazu dass wir
diesen pfahrt fortsetzen denn der Staat
das will ich offen sagen der Staat muss
mit dem Geld auskommen was ihm die
Steuerzahlerin und Steuerzahler zur
Verfügung stellen sie müssen jetzt
mindestens 17 Milliarden fürs kommenden
Jahr irgendwoh herholen ein mögliches
Mittel wären Steuererhöhungen da hat
sich die FDP immer sehr stark gegen
gesträubt die SPD hat jetzt gerade auf
dem Parteitag noch einmal den Vorschlag
gemacht eine einmalabgabe für
Superreiche wäre das eine
Kompromisslinie nein nein also
Steuererhöhung einem höchststeuerland
verbieten sich und da wird immer von
Superreichen gesprochen es sind ja in
aller Regel mittelständische
Familienunternehmer die Unternehmen
investiert sind das heißt man besteuert
hier nichts anderes als Arbeitsplätze es
ist vollkommen in Ordnung dass in einer
Koalition die Partner unterschiedliche
steuerpolitische Auffassung haben die
haben wir auch und das ist legitim aber
eigentlich sind wir uns beim fah der
Konsolidierung da ist mein Rat jetzt für
die kommenden Tage wo weiter gesprochen
wird dass wir diesen
konsolidierungspahrt eben nicht
verlassen denn wir sehen erste Erfolge
die Schuldenquote geht zurück und Frau
benergy das interessiert sicherlich alle
Zuschauer die Inflation geht in
Deutschland zurück diese Schuldenbremse
auf die wir bestehen die ist auch eine
nicht unser Thema unser Thema ist die
Frage wie kommen sie in das Geld wenn
ich ihnen so zuhöre habe ich den
Eindruck der Kanzler will bei sozialem
hart bleiben und sie wollen bei steuern
und bei der Schuldenbremse hart bleiben
wenn sie da nicht zusammenkommen müssen
wir uns da nicht eigentlich auf
neuichten nein ich will die Dimension
deutlich machen der Bundeshaushalt wird
im Kommen der etwa 450 Milliarden Euro
umfassen das ist wesentlich mehr als
noch zu vor coronazeiten das heißt das
Volumen insgesamt ist eigentlich größer
geworden wir haben gleichzeitig
konsolidiert und jetzt schaut man sich
das in Ruhe und zwar in der Ruhe die das
Verfassungsgericht zurecht uns
beigebracht hat schauen wir uns in der
Ruhe ganz genau an wo man sparen kann wo
man auch hier und da kürzen kann damit
man einen soliden Haushalt aufstellt
denn Solidität muss doch jetzt gelten
das haben die Bundesländer jetzt noch
vor sich der Bund liefert jetzt und wir
sind gespannt wie dann eine mögliche
Lösung aussieht herzlichen Dank erst
einmal für das Gespräch ich danke Ihnen